SO GOING TO A BALL GAME AND
WEARING A MASK, FOR ME I VOTE TO
WEAR THE MASK AND GO TO THE
BALL GAME.
AMERICANS WILL MAKE THEIR OWN
CHOICE.
AND ALSO TONIGHT PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO FULFILL HIS PROMISE TO GET
RID OF BURDENS OF GALATIANS.
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO AGENCY TO
CUT OUT RULES THAT WILL IMPEDE
ECONOMIC COMEBACK.
THAT IS NOT ALL BECAUSE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO
MOVING AHEAD ON PLANS TO BUILD
THE NATION’S FIRST STOCKPILE OF
KEY DRUG INGREDIENTS.
THIS IS CRUCIAL NOW.
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO RELY ON
CHINA, WHICH AS WE HAVE TOLD
YOU, HAS COVERED UP THE EXTENT
OF THIS OUTBREAK ALONG WITH THE
W.H.O.
AND PROMPTING, BY THE WAY, THE
PRESIDENT SENT A BLISTERING
LETTER TO THE W.H.O. CHIEF LATE
MONDAY MORNING, THERE WILL BE A
PERMANENT PLANTING FREEZE IF THE
W.H.O. DOESN’T MAKE MAJOR
REFORMS IN THE NEXT 30 DAYS.
HERE WITH TOM COTTON, THE
PROPOSED LEGISLATION TO BAN
STATES FROM STIMULUS FUNDS IF
SPENDING ON ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
FIRST THE CHINA QUESTION, WHAT
WE DID NOT REALIZE AND NOW WE
DO, A LOT OF OUR MEDICAL SUPPLY
CHAIN IS RIGHT OUT OF CHINA.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS, THEY
WOULDN’T ALLOW ANY TRAVEL FROM
CHINA INTO WUHAN OR FROM WUHAN
INTO OTHER AREAS OF CHINA BUT
THEY LEFT OPEN TO THE WORLD.
THEN THEY WERE TAKING UP AND
BUYING UP THE WORLD’S MEDICAL
SUPPLIES.
AND A LOT OF CHEMICAL AGENTS
THAT WE NEED FOR OUR
PHARMACEUTICALS, WE ARE RELYING
ON THEM FOR A PIER THAT HAS GOT
TO STOP, SENATOR.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, SEAN IT IS A
TRAGIC IRONY THAT THE COUNTRY
ROUTE RELEASE THIS PANDEMIC ON
THE WORLD ALSO CONTROLS MANY OF
THE BASIC PHARMACEUTICAL
INGREDIENTS FOR THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT DOES HAVE TO STOP.
AND LEGISLATION TO GIVE
INCENTIVES TO BUILD MORE
MANUFACTURING IN THE
UNITED STATES AND ULTIMATELY
BANNED THE IMPORT FROM
PHARMACEUTICALS FROM CHINA WHICH
MANY UNADULTERATED TO BEGIN
WITH.
AND I COMMEND THE PRESIDENT
MOVING FORWARD WITH
PHARMACEUTICAL MANUFACTURING IN
THE UNITED STATES TO TRY TO
BUILD UP THAT STOCKPILE SO WE
DON’T FIND OURSELVES IN THIS
POSITION EVER AGAIN.
>> Sean: NEW YORK, ILLINOIS,
NEW JERSEY, CALIFORNIA, OKAY,
THEY HAVE SOME OF THE HIGHEST
STATE INCOME TAXES IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
NOW, THERE IS MORE WASTE, FRAUD,
ABUSE, DEBT, DEFICITS.
THEY ARE NOW TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE LIKE YOURSELF AND PEOPLE
IN RED STATES THAT ELECT
RESPONSIBLE POLITICIANS, THAT
DON’T TAX AND SPEND TO DEATH TO
BAIL THEM OUT.
THAT MEANS BAIL OUT THEIR
STUPIDITY.
NOW, YOU TALK ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
HOW MUCH IS THAT CONSTANT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR, THE
STATE OF NEW YORK EVERY YEAR?
A LOT OF MONEY.
YOU ARE SAYING NOBODY SHOULD GET
ANY MONEY UNLESS THEY GET RID OF
THESE POLICIES.
>> YEAH, THAT IS RIGHT, SEAN.
WE SHOULDN’T BE SPENDING HARD
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS 1:30 5 MILLION
AMERICANS ARE OUT OF WORK.
IF WE GIVE RELIEF CHECKS FOR
THOSE PEOPLE OUT OF WORK, WE